great now we could keep going up and
play this game for a while I think most
of us and there are squares up to like
maybe 10 or 11 or 12 okay
but this is enough for us to illustrate
something unusual okay which is that
look for these numbers you can go this
way and everything's nice and neat but
there are loads of numbers loads of
square roots that are nice and neat and
here's what you're going to need your
calculator okay so let's just pick out a
number like say between 4 and 9 there's
a the square root of say 7 the square
root of 7 okay now when you took squared
1 squared 4 square root of 9 square root
of 25 they're all nice numbers but if
you get your calculator out and I would
actually like us to plug this in you'll
find the square root button sort of
towards the top left in one of those
small gray buttons not the black ones
when you press equals you know weird
funky number you see that what do you
get so I'm gonna write what I've got on
my screen I'd like you to do the same
okay
I've got two point six four five seven
five one three one one okay does that
make sure that you got yes good
excellent okay so we're so far we can
press funds on our calculators
successfully now let's notice a couple
of interesting please you firstly even
though your calculator doesn't say if
this is literally what my calculator six
your calculator actually means this is
something a little bit different and
this is a really important thing I'm
gonna it's so important and put it on
color see how I've got one two three
four five six seven eight nine nine
decimal places okay but the square of
seven doesn't actually have nine decimal
places that's just as many as my
calculator can show so what the
calculator means when you should put
this in like another color if you've got
one is dot dot dot write the number
actually keeps going and it goes on
forever this is very strange
okay if my calculator had a bigger
screen and in fact later I'm not right
now but comes first and you turn it
sideways so that you can see more digits
on it you should get more than
your calculator shows this is very
unusual let me show you why we've looked
at decimals before we look the decimals
and some decimals are really nice and
neat okay so example if you remember
think back to fractions last year okay
lots of fractions can be written as a
nice neat decimal for example aha
what's the decimal version Omaha yep
yeah very good zero fine okay now
because the decimal point it just just
stops there's a little more after that
we call this a terminating decimal
terminated because you know like I am if
you've been on a train it's like this
train terminates at this station so it's
it's not it doesn't go any further
terminating decimal there are other
fractions though where the decimal
doesn't terminate it keeps going right
for example just after a half is a third
okay so if anyone knows a third when I
write the decimal but what does it look
like yeah very good
so 3 3 a whole bunch of threes just like
this I'm good dot-dot-dot bless you
there's another by the way there's a
shorter way of writing it rather than
writing a whole bunch of threes they
don't remember yeah very good yeah so we
called this dot up here because it's
making that digit repeat over and over
again we call it our repeater
it's a repeater oh so that guy up there
is a repeater and I'm I heard the word
just now rather than a terminating
decimal this decimal goes on and on and
on forever we call it a recurring
decimal okay now I'm trying to show you
why this is so read that this is this
kind of number up here it goes on
forever because this goes on forever as
well right let me give you a musical
energy because I like music a
terminating decimal
what Saturnian decimal if you imagine a
terminating decimal like a piece of
music okay it's kind of like a pop song
how long's a pop song three minutes four
minutes three and a half something like
that right very seldom will you get a
song much longer than that my point is
though
it starts and it ends that's it that's
the song a recurring decimal it was a
piece of music I kind of imagined like
you know if you ever get into I'm in a
hotel
my fancy hotel if you get into an
elevator right it's not quiet there's
music in the background it's kind of
this like quiet like dude and just goes
on forever and ever if you get out of
the elevator and you come back an hour
later the music is still going just like
this decimal is still going right so I
call this elevated music now it's
important that it's you know it's it's
like an elevator because if you go in
and you listen it's still the same music
you like I recognize this it's just on a
loop over okay now let's compare that
now to our Weiner friend up here the
square root of seven the square root of
seven hmm excuse me if you and write
down these numbers the weird thing about
this is that well we already noticed it
doesn't terminate it keeps going but it
doesn't do this either it doesn't recur
it doesn't repeat you can't do this
repeater thing you can't put a dot on
any of these numbers yeah if I kept
going and I will actually for the sake
of illustration if I had a look at what
the rest of the numbers were I'm gonna
keep getting different numbers alright
so let me just pull this up excuse me
clear okay so my calculators got a few
more digits on it not my phone rather
not that many Biltmore though it goes
you might like to write these down with
me zero six no you might see it's a
couple of repeats look six four five
again that's kind of weird
but even though that little chunk is
repeated he goes different again right
and if I could never completely repeat
but just think about how we this is for
a second turn a decimal this is a
recurring decimal right this is just a
decimal that never ends doesn't
special name what kind of music would
this mean hmm
how many of you play a musical
instrument hands up hands up straight so
what music what is what you play
basically huh sax jump it
electric guitar fit house think I'm
acoustic caliber yep trumpet and oh
great thank you keyboard now just think
it all those instruments right but some
more than others particularly cuz I know
what's my train of thought which was my
instruments where we yeah okay good for
something students more than others and
because I also have to play it I know
for a fact the bass guitar the bass
guitar more than most instruments is a
bit like this speed like this right and
it would just play sometimes for a whole
song gonna play the same four notes over
and over again right so some needs to
repeat but some in strips and some
styles of music kind of like this I
think you one place has jazz music is
renowned for being built on
improvisation
like they're making stuff up they don't
have like a big sheet in front of me
like reading off the notes they're
literally inventing the music as they go
okay this guy here is not just like jazz
music because he's making it up as it
goes right he's like a crazy you know
immortal jazz musician okay because
think about this he's making up new
music and he's making up new music
forever that's crazy how long can you
play music for I didn't play music for
power play music for about 22 years okay
and with all of that musical sort of you
know in my head I can play maybe like
three or four hours but constantly news
and then eventually I'll be like oh I'll
forget and I'll revert back to something
that I knew before but these guys right
and in fact lots of numbers like him
infinite number even they just keep on
and I'm da da da they just keep on
making new music forever that's nuts
okay so we have this this kind of number
is a really important class of number it
is called a cert okay these numbers here
which involves square roots and they
don't they don't simplify out nicely
they're not like the square root of 4 or
the square root of 9 or the square of 25
we call them ok now there's one other
important label that I'm going to give
these and labels are important in maths
as in every subject cuz they help you to
describe things it's not because we want
you to memorize terms it's because like
now I can talk about these and
understand them down right see how these
are fractions right their fractions and
another word for fractures that starts
with an R is a ratio it's like a ratio
between two different numbers between 1
and 2 or between 1 and 3 thirds can
never ever ever be written in the form
of a fraction or ratio just can't do it
right it's not like all the square root
of 7 it's about 3/4 or about seven
quarters or whatever right this new
fraction is equal no ratio that it gives
you so we call them irrational
irrational numbers so not irrational
like you're being irrational you crazy
man we mean you can't be like a ratio
cut right in the photo frame